what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation I'm rejoined by the real
Aaron Alexander over here because today
we are going to watch the 2014 version
of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Heroes
at a half shell turtle power yes so
Aaron uh has never seen these films
specifically the ones produced by
Michael Bay I saw
this one
once when it first came out I don't
remember it that well in fact I don't
even know what happens I I was telling
you before I'm like I think Shredder
might be in this one and we think Tyler
Perry's him Tyler Perry might be in it I
know that he plays bastard Stockman
that's literally the only thing I know
about this movie okay and if the turtles
are like way ginormous for some reason
yeah they're like gross or something uh
but uh yeah when it comes to the
re-watches for myself it's like I can't
do the re-watches for the ones that came
out in the 90s because I remember those
too well but you know when I choose to
be a part of one of these videos it's
gonna be like oh I saw it once when I
was younger don't really remember it it
could feel like a fun fresh experience
or like the turtles I was a little too
green if you know what I mean and uh
that means I really don't remember so
I'm pretty sure it's the latter based
off of the year when this came out or
knowing what I was doing every single
day morning noon and night so ladies and
gentlemen with that in mind leave a like
on this video that'd be very much
appreciated also be sure to follow us on
our patreon page become a super sexy
reject because that is where you will
get the full-length Reaction watch along
where you sing it with your own copy of
TMM and lastly this reaction will be
edited by the team over at prepper so
the videos crap blame them but if it's
great or need of help with an editor go
hire them choice is yours let's do this
[Music]
that's cool it's animated that's really
cool a criminal organization known as
the as the Foot Clan yes the leader the
Shredder the shredder is in this one
okay
[Music]
and we begin
let's be one with the blades
lead their path
hey this looks cool that's all they did
was cut random objects
Fruit Ninja you're not yet ready to go
above ground but I believe when that day
comes and you rise to the street this
looks like a Nike commercial from the
2000s
when the time come Turtles just do it 10
guys storm in here broad daylight forces
to the ground at gunpoint Benzel Cyanide
and some damnating ages too this feels
so serious is there anybody else cooking
these sort of chemicals besides you
there's one other high security
[Laughter]
you're in this movie who the hell are
you celebrity Fitness to Harley
pasternack hi Harley morning April April
20 years I've studied the animal kingdom
there are fat pigs there are fat cows
there are no fat birds I don't know if
that tracks so we're gonna squat down
and flap your wings
is this a real workout routine if it is
it's stupid I say that we go to my
buddy's old restaurant downtown it's
very vibey because there's eight on the
way over here no I know we just I'm not
saying for a full meal we're just
getting app
etizers I love in movies when the women
can't tell how obvious they're trying to
get picked up
[Laughter]
this movie looks like it was directed by
Michael Bay it does right the Angles and
the shaky cam the lighting
hold on
damn This Woman's been biking for hours
that's how she gets her Fitness in not
over there that bird was after she
was flapping while biking right
foreign
big freaky turtles
[Music]
I like the sound design so far though
oh
what the shell was that
what is that what the it's either Asian
letters or a big smudge
attack are you okay I was riding my bike
by the dock damn she dries off well
super dry it's the flaps unless you
flapped her way out
water shook up all right we need a lead
for tonight Who's got a major
redevelopments proposed for Lower
Manhattan no Whoopi Goldberg gold bricks
in this room
there is a vigilante that is fighting
back against the Foot Clan there's a
huge story here I think you found
Superman that's cool what a ridiculous
story April the ninjas are real but what
you're talking about and Saturday
I took this photo on one of the shipping
containers
[Applause]
that's a lot clearer than what we saw
earlier you wanted me to put nothing on
the Nightly News of course not you know
I'm gonna pretend we never had this
conversation I'm erasing it from my mind
you're so stupid April you're you're
dumb little we don't even know why we
hire you we all hate you
[Laughter]
suck everyone to reach relationship
sure to God
this is interesting we're like 15
minutes in and we still haven't seen the
turtles no goddamn turtles yeah that's
kind of crazy
and nothing's interesting
how about that
sweet sauce
can't even tie him up can't tie me down
we couldn't have anticipated the Visual
Land is showing up at the dogs Master
Shredder Shredder
um
they're not human why is he speaking
Japanese and she's speaking English no
one will stop us in our quest to reclaim
Victory we will own this city I actually
did enjoy that Shredder portrayal of the
tiny bit we just got seems a little bit
intimidating a little spooky yeah it's
got that nice menacing baritone to his
voice I haven't seen you since uh since
his funeral
it was a long time ago
well you got hot since he died
channel six very impressive apron so he
brought me to take care of you
it isn't exactly everything I anticipate
are you kidding I started doing the bird
workouts Because of You
[Laughter]
surveilling somethings are showing heavy
heavy Foot Clan activity at the Broad
Street platform Market taking hostages
dude what you know we're not supposed to
go above ground oh these are the turtles
hmm that cat is playing chopsticks with
chopsticks don't be an idiot ah okay
let's rock and roll boys
some Batman Robin Vibes
I appreciate the cinematography
constantly going for things that
reflected
colors of the turtles
I mean this is just dangerously stupid
what do you think was gonna happen
Oh I thought the Foot Clan were dressed
like ninjas
why would you think such a thing
[Laughter]
Amanda we start executing hostages
good
subtle that black lady had the right
impression like what the hell are you
doing
[Music]
some cool Turtle come on damn ouch
Jesus aggressive Turtles
oh my God that's pretty cool it was cool
you were a murderer that guy's
definitely dead
oh my God murder everybody
they're gonna love you kill the hostages
cut their heads off
some kind of freak yeah
some kind of freak just safe this
well now April's gonna have a lot of
eyewitness testimonies of people who
were saying that they saw some
Vigilantes out there who saved us
he'll be drinking out of a sippy cup for
a month oh that's what I'm talking about
brothers like shadows in the night
completely unseen
we know it's a camera flash who's behind
the camera
[Laughter]
oh
geez give me the camera oh my God he's
doing his Batman voice
Turtle toe wow they are monstrous
she's so hot I can feel myself
[Music]
don't say that
my colleague here forgot to say please
whoa oh my God
chill just ask
don't freak out
it's worse
that's the appropriate response I don't
know why I kind of like that they look
absolutely horrifying
they feel like real mutated creatures to
me
are you well miss uh we're ninjas no
you're not why are you lying to me
mutant turtle
teenagers well when you put it like that
it sounds ridiculous close enough I
guess do not say a word about this to
anyone if you do we will find you their
skin is so slimy creepy
all right April it's time to go back to
your news station
they have a booster pack what the what's
going on their feet
whoa okay that's a cool shot yeah oh
it's a skateboard of the boosters okay
[Music]
I bet dramatic push
emptying this box
[Music]
no way what she's linked to their lore
what's happening this feels like Amazing
Spider-Man 2 now
it's all connected I know it sounds
pretty boring but actually he does some
pretty cool stuff time to put the camera
away April her dad made the turtles dude
are you for real right now
I'm supposed to be from a different
planet oh my God
it's a very complicated question Mr Sax
you nuts
this is wild
even got the color coordinated shells oh
my goodness super Turtles
so they were her pets
pet turtles I'm coming out on my own
first chance I get are we gonna finish
our hip-hop Christmas album bro you're
the hype man
I noticed there's like barely any
cutting when it comes to their
interactions kind of interesting like
the human scenes have a lot of cutting
but with the turtles they do a lot of
just tracking shots
whoa splinty Where Have You Been we
weren't damn I forgot to soak my
retainer
disciplinary it's a big ass tail enough
you disobeyed a direct order why did you
go above ground what happened to the
Hershey
why'd they give spinner a few Man true
man just like that in the comics or
cartoon it's fine I was awake all night
please look I was awake all night April
Googling all
appeared at
no you don't you don't move on April you
just focus on the turtle thing
just just don't even talk about it until
you got the figured out like but is
there anything else we should know about
them they're ninjas I'm sorry what
and they do karate
April why didn't you show the piece of
footage where the super strength turtle
was smashing through the glass
to be like they evolved they grew up you
sound real smart when you say they do
karate don't just show footage of normal
Turtle Behavior
sure the odd Parts seven hours
I ain't breaking if Donnie ain't
breaking who are the voice actors I know
Alan Richardson is wrath yeah the 99
cheese pizza
it's not possible oh pizza with that
variety of cheese is a culinary
impossibility
yeah dude
provolone
keep it together I love you creepy we
left the layer because the foot we're
taking hostages and we kicked some
serious butter there was this girl named
April O'Neil who took our picture oh no
my worst fears have been realized
splinters are real Jonathan Kent
[Laughter]
April O'Neil who is in danger find the
girl bring her here we'll eat her with
the pizza
Splinter trained them to be Master
ninjas but never wanted them to leave
the sewers yeah to protect themselves
from the humans that can totally do
damage to them come on it's not that
crazy I the animal kingdom is full of
I used to have a dog that could moonwalk
this guy will say anything to get laid
I have this theater there are these
vigilantes that are fighting back
against the foot I think that you and my
father may have created them
I'm not sure all this Asian ninja
symbolism is uh kind of a little there's
even
some Samurai armor in the back there we
lost all our research in the fire all
our specimens everything you didn't lose
everything in the fire I hope you
surprised
my babies
I was a powerless and helpless boy until
a local Sensei took me under his wing
taught me lessons that I later shared
with your father so it's definitely
helping the Clan right an evil
warlord Ruled the Land he poisoned the
water supply a hero Rose a great
Alchemist discovered the antidote the
cure-all for his evil what was it we
developed a mutagen capable of
stimulating self-repair on a cellular
level Something Like An ooze those
Turtles is the last of this precious
mutagen how could they have lived
because I saved them what when how
bam you've been hacked by Donatello meet
us here to come alone or or else work
you shall be punished stuff this movie
does not have a great grip on its tone
no it's kind of all over the place and
like I don't really care what's
happening with April
it's a little too serious and then it
tries to balance it out with like comedy
right but the comedy just is a little
it's mostly bad cringy and flat yeah I
think the turtles themselves are the
only enjoyable part of the movie so far
you brought us here April
did you tell her his name maybe she's
clear maybe she's a Jedi I want to buy
an orange crush now right of course the
orange one will be drinking the orange
crush the bouquet is not bad though on
the turtles no I think spider looks
weird though that's what it looks
freaking crazy yeah
why don't they just make him Shredder I
was gonna say I feel like they're gonna
pull like a dark knight I mean they're
gonna pull up Batman Begins and like you
think the other guy shredder but he's
actually a shredder
cause everybody would love that he's the
student of Shredder oh okay they're
alive Master Shredder it won't be easy
to capture them but if we can can
finally carry out the plan that we had
all those years ago but they want to
like extract their DNA I guess yeah
O'Neill's daughter was the one who found
them and she will be the one who will
take us right to them oh damn there's
the pink he preached the cloaking
security
I understand they're like the turtles
have been like really serious in the
comics and stuff and you as always
provided us with a special treat I'm
surprised they let the turtles eat pizza
can't be healthy diet for for Turtles
you're relying on your science
experiment for words
your father had discovered the truth
behind the man he was working for He Set
Fire to the lab his last breath was
taken trying to destroy Shredder's Bird
right ah yes yes yes
but then you appeared
he did this with his daughter there
until I found this place in it was then
that the mutagen that was injected into
our blood
on the stop-motion animation is this
fascinating time lapse I became their
father and they became my sons
they would need to learn to protect
themselves both mentally and physically
CGI broom
[Laughter]
yeah I think they they wanted to build
that organic chemistry with the turtles
so they had them all motion captured in
the same space which is either don't cut
around them the brothers
accelerating at a wondrous rate
I do like the action video okay I'm not
gonna lie to you I think the action
looks pretty cool man their gift was
also their passion
why does Raphael hate everyone the
katana most noble of all the blades it
is the weapon of a leader
he just designated Leonardo as the
leader
all these years you told us we were
rescued from the fire by a great
Guardian Spirit a hogo shot she is the
one this is the hogosha
I like the Aesthetics of the turtles
attire how it feels like janky and worn
out like it's all from like a junkyard
or something yeah like all stuff that's
like fallen into the sewers that they
kind of like self-made for style yeah I
think it's cool refining the robotics in
your armor we're taking it to the next
level Bridging the Gap between ancient
tradition and Modern Warfare
Shredder
and Shredder
Sheen upgrades nobody that believed me
I'm gonna grate all the cheese except
for Eric sacks just as I feared you told
the one guy you weren't supposed to tell
April
his soul has been poisoned the doctor
the Shredder the shredder is a skilled
Warrior and you are just teenagers just
teenagers look at them you know they're
freaking huge dude they're not teenagers
no the sex has confirmation that you are
alive I fear they will bring the fight
to us so far the only ones that really
feel like they have personality or or
Mikey and wrath Mikey's the only one
that feels like a teenager forever
it's Turtle time
it's murder time
no get back oh it's weird that was a
weird shot the Turtle base infiltrated
in their first movie good job guys
all right get him
that's what I'm talking about
wow this Leonardo's murdering them
what's up bro oh you think you can
handle this huh
nice
I do like the choreographer the Tails
always oh my God damn damn come with me
I got a safe place for you to hide and
if you get thirsty I got a secret stash
of Orange Crush behind the fridge
whoa oh damn
as Michelangelo was moving but April
shot she was just still you will not lay
a hand on my sons
you think you're the owner
Mecca Shredder that's so extra dude
that's so that's the most 90s thing I've
ever seen
do the Turtles kill I mean they have
swords and like yeah you would think
right
[Music]
feders cut his tail off that's his like
his maximum
that's his biggest strength right there
I love it
I'm so conflicted about this a whole
Mecca Shredder thing I'm not it's dumb
it's stupid
[Music]
way to go April look what you brought
here
MVP
you stupid little girl hey bro
oh splinter
[Music]
I overall say I like the Splinter
portrayal though
what are you doing
are you gonna kill are you gonna kill
him in the first movie are you for real
right now
that's how we're starting this
he is getting messed up damn drop your
weapons oh yeah
we'll die
this movie really thinks it's super
dramatic and weighty
it thinks it's so epic
where's the fourth he's dead it's just
kind of registers
throwing it already oh Raph probably got
away right because he's the only one to
be on his own anyway yeah I was trying
to say like 20 minutes ago it's like I
know that of course the cereals have
been really dark and serious In Like
Comics and stuff before there's
something about this that feels like a
weird YouTube video where they just like
we want to do a super serious take on
the turtles and it feels like that
without any self-awareness it feels like
it wants to be serious but has done
nothing to warmth the tone that it's
trying to go for like there's nothing of
substance to back up this series serious
town it's all very kind of like on the
surface
that's a very Michael Bay shot
you must save your brothers
damn it's just 2014. yeah it feels like
it's from an earlier era like 2000s like
2007 or something yeah two thousands
late 90s somewhere there something out
of like the Daredevil feels like Ghost
Rider era I see that yeah like 2005 era
yeah totally
minutes please all right let me meet you
right now
I'll play your little game
bad down tremendous we don't need to
make up excuses to hang out with each
other you want to spend more time with
me I get it I would you need to get to
the sax estate right now that's what I'm
talking about O'Neil the saxes stayed
with the vicious whoa you're a talking
turtle and you're a human nerd now that
we got that out of the way hit it
all we were trying to do is create an
anecdote for what
well um we had this plan
I think Willie Victor is always so good
at anything he does that Spire is filled
with tons of chemical toxins
why
to take over or something is going to
unleash all that stuff over the whole
city are we gonna get a sky beam we'll
shake World governments to their core
the city of New York will be a
quarantine Zone legit and we're going to
provide the Cure I'm Gonna Save everyone
with the antidote
from the mutagen that is oozing through
your blood oozing is that the word I'm
Gonna Be Rich like
stupid Rich you're already stupid rich
I'm gonna be richer all right everybody
damn
hey get out of here
oh man it was not a not that much work
for Raphael not this plan would be a
little bit more intricate and difficult
I was very you just found them super
easy barely inconvenience
Raphael
glad you could join us super duper
Shredder okay no this is what I was
waiting for
Super Shredder that's a thing oh he has
14 knives on each hand he's super duper
Shredder Greg
come on
well focus on getting the Turtles out
come on back knives ouch
what do I do
what
a friend of mine what adrenaline oh
[Music]
good thing that was the first option
right there
you can hear the chill cracking yeah
yeah that's nasty
[Music]
it's so over the top here is
laughs
like it just feels like desperate to be
taken serious right yeah we are the
dramatic Turtles damn it
[Music]
such a weird Mash of tones yeah I know
like he wants to be so serious one
minute and kind of goofy the next it's
so odd and it's not like so bad it's
entertaining you know yeah it's kind of
weird it's just somewhere in the middle
it's kind of man everybody calm down
look how calm I am feels like the movie
is like we want to be serious but Mikey
you're a comic release well it's also so
much more April's movie than it is that
it really is they're barely characters
in this movie Man
muscle essentially
[Music]
are turtle shells Bulletproof
oh what it just repelled them out of his
chest okay all right because shells can
do that I feel like Donny's stuff would
be like way too bulky as all that like
all that gear on him you know and none
of it's been like put to play it's just
all Aesthetics
sewer line 2.4 miles from here like a
oh it's about to happen
I like that you some numb Chuck it's not
gonna lie
ouch
where are they again I don't know Eric
in the snow who cares
I've always wanted to try this
let's try what
[Music]
That's How Strong your stick is
damn
great aim
wow this is getting wildly out of hand
come on Leo wake up yeah you wake up I
promise to do anything you say
I don't know about you for me it's like
it's cool like visually but it's getting
to that point it's like just so much
like happening on the screen like I
don't really like care there's a 500
foot drop off in 53 seconds
get April out of there oh it's got a bit
of that Michael Bay uh you know like a
lot of noise effect yeah yeah it's just
visual noise yeah I was watching
oh that was a really cool POV shot damn
okay oh yeah oh that's cool that's a
great shots you see have this moment
yeah oh that's cool I like that
[Music]
there are some impressive visuals
hey guys it's the maintenance hatch our
ticket home a little help please guys we
gotta hustle shredders over New York
City the benefit to the fact that our
Turtles are CGI like mocap CGI is that
whenever they do these like crazy
tracking shots in any capacity whether
the movement of the truck it weirdly
feels like tangible unbelievable as
opposed to when it's a human character
because then you notice when the human
is CGI so you're like oh it's an
impressive shot yeah I get you I see
that yeah
you can yeah it does give you a lot more
freedom it feels more seamless because
you're not distracted by when it's CGI
as long as it's just them it's fine
[Laughter]
but no they're not real characters and I
have no idea what Leonardo's the leader
we don't make it back bring the mutagen
splinter
it can save his life
the movie keeps saying they're teenagers
but because they have the voices of like
grown acetones and none of their actions
either at all teenagery yeah
I feel more like frat Bros yeah
you can kick their asses first vile is
filling with antidote now
initiating the toxin release okay is
there is there a guy in there or is that
just a Mech that's one thing I'm not
clear about
I mean I feel like there might be a guy
human Shredder is in there he's in there
okay he feels very mecky
MC monkey
movie comedy
[Music]
breaks
I did get it though it was a little fun
segment hey Mikey remember that thing
used to say when we were kids you made
me promise never to say it again forget
about that
still got one in the tank Cowabunga
Cowabunga wow
that Shredder suit looks so heavy how
does he move around so fast that's why
I'm like is there a guy in there are we
sure do you think a samurai would want
to be like lighter you know yeah you
think the most fear ruthless fighter
would I need a giant Mecca suit you
would think
I'll take it come on
of course he has a mega sword of course
of course he has a dual wielding sword
as they do in Japan
[Music]
why would he use the nump truck why
would he use the dump trucks
I understand a girl with dead daddy
issues I do but you're not gonna stop me
if your father walked into me April took
a few less bullets to take him down
though
the bed today
foreign
[Music]
ER feels like such an afterthought too
I'll say this fight's kind of cool the
fight's cool but Cheryl feels like a
secondary villain where the cool fights
are given to him and William fichner's
the main villain right who wants to play
buck buck buck
what all right William figures the
the face and he's the muscle when I'm
like the movie's saying that's not the
case but it certainly feels like that
shredder has no personality in this
movie at all he's just a guy and a suit
with an intimidating voice that's it
this feels like tasm won with the
stuff coming down
also with them being on top of a
building and it's gonna spray stuff into
the atmosphere
[Music]
hmm
oh you know he's been that would
definitely his neck he would not be
a person anymore
[Music]
oh he throws them too awesome
we have the limited knives what the hell
oh cause he's bringing him back with the
magnets yeah okay
[Music]
for everybody dude you're gonna get
stabbed man
it's gonna bring it down Chasm Style
that is evil nobody moves no matter what
his voice is so deep for no reason dude
I'm Letting Go
jeez
this is all that's left little girl
what's the plan here
oh my God
how what no way
[Music]
oh my God The Whole World's Gonna See
you guys
I gotcha
[Music]
April took down the shredder
that was a great shot that was a really
great shot that's pretty cool
I so did not understand the ending of
lost I'm sorry I was so hard on you ugh
every time I push you I there's a brand
on your shoulder you see that and every
time I talked about walking away it was
because I was scared I just didn't think
I was good enough to stand next to you
and call you Brothers It's wow I love
you
I love you guys so much
there's gonna be a joke
you crying I don't think though
it's a little Dusty out here oh that was
sweet that was sweet I like movies I
always want Raphael to be the main
character because he's the most
compelling one he's got the dark Edge
Shredder will rise Super Shredder you're
alive it worked
was all my
fault why is the Leonardo's fault I
don't know
oh you needed us to discover that your
true power lies in believing in one
another I don't believe that for one
second I was gonna say did they learn
that
is that a thing that was uh supposed to
be an arc oh I guess he like learned to
trust Leo but like that was like I
didn't really feel like any of this
movie was about them not knowing how to
work together right right
it was an arc a little half-assed art
did you get a new car
you're looking at the new Fenwick no
matter how physically intense this movie
gets April has looked the exact same in
every shot not a scratch on her not a
sweat bead on her forehead
makeup fully intact
foreign
Turtle van who made that for you guys we
owed you a thanks for keeping our secret
you know you had a lot to gain from
telling people about us
that you had our backs
yeah that's what families Mark Wahlberg
playing him
I swear it's Alan Richardson what is it
doing his best Mark Wahlberg impression
check the base bruh
[Music]
uh oh
still figuring out the buttons that was
my new Fenwick Express
I just I just got that we better get out
of here
[Music]
sweet
cool
oh is there after credit scene do
they do those
oh no I hope there's still more
haha
that was dumb I don't know why I laughed
at that
the two best Turtles
that's funny
I've never heard this song before
okay bringing it back to the 90s making
movie themed wraps okay
all righty well
um
you're kind of expressing our thought
process through it yeah I think my I I
think you significantly disliked way
more than me uh I would say so yeah
maybe you should have given me a heads
up that you saw the 96 Rotten Tomatoes
review TMNT in the theaters a few days
ago
which would put you in the mindset of
perhaps wanting a better Turtles
but for me I'm like ah yeah I'm I don't
know any of that cast out of Alan
Richardson uh but for for me I was like
yeah this is uh very middle of the
ground it's it's it reeks of Michael
Bay's touch the whole time even though
he didn't direct it
it has that air of
like this needed to be a little bit more
to me Transformers rise of the Beast and
less than Michael Bay movies that that
he did for Transformers where it was
like we got the granted you get more
time with turtles than you do with like
Transformers being characters here but
the trans but the turtles still feel
like
um they're a bit of an afterthought and
they're not as well balanced with the
human tale of April nor does the Arc of
April really tie in that strongly with
whatever Arc they've shoved in there
about the turtles like it doesn't feel
like it ultimately coalesces together by
the end if unlike
Transformers rise of the Beast which I'm
going to compare to because I thought
they did a great job with having our
human lead and then having uh Optimus
Prime as our lead and watching how their
arcs dovetailed into each other by the
end you know what I mean and I feel like
in some way a movie needed that touch
and this is from that era of films like
right now they're advertising the movie
Rampage to us which again is like we
need Dwayne Johnson we'll make him the
human lead in here and then here April
O'Neil which is a character from like a
staple of the turtles Lauren world but
it did ring like
for some reason
um
like I actually I don't dislike Megan
Fox as an actress in in the way how like
she got a whole bunch of hate at one
point you know uh I saw Jennifer's Body
only last year I thought she was great
in it and even here I feel like she's
fine I just think the writing overall of
everything and everyone does not give
any real uh uh wait to Warrant the
journey and stuff and yeah I think we
made it pretty clear on like tonally
where the movie was
fluctuating but it was it was like a
real middling experience and I get now
why I completely forgot about everything
had nothing to do with whatever you're
consuming yeah I mean yeah it definitely
did date in that especially a movie like
this and see it in the theaters under uh
the MJ influence I would have the
hardest time processing what's happening
in the film because it's just like
there's too many shots there's too much
moving around and even not under it
right now I was like this feels like
some weird
I felt I felt that when I said it felt
like a dream it it feels like
I watched the Ninja Turtles and then I
went to sleep and then I had a nightmare
version of the Ninja Turtles like some
weird altered nightmare take on it and
not in the sense that it's a horror
movie it's it's not it's not a very
Charming film The Turtles don't become
necessarily Charming
it doesn't have that effect of like E.T
wear oh my God it's creepy but then you
learn to love him right you're like no
there's they're like fine by the end I'm
not like creeped out by them but
the the off-putting factor of them
doesn't exactly go away entirely by the
end you know it's no it's still weird
from from start to finish and I know it
was kind of shitty on the movie lives
we're watching it but I don't think the
movie's terrible like I think there's
some cool aspects to the movie like well
the movie's an easy target to be fair
I know you kind of said that like like
my maybe a little bit my my recent
experience with the new one played a
part but I I can appreciate different
interpretations and not have them
weighed down I think the movie itself is
what was weighing itself down I think of
course yeah a thousand percent yeah and
I just think that
for me personally I'm someone who's
attracted to movies that have characters
that the driving focus of the movie and
I think that everyone in this movie is
very one no like April had no flaws her
only thing is she she wanted to get the
story and then she wanted to help the
turtles and that's it and it's just it
was just very
simple in that way and the plot wasn't
very compelling either I think it was it
just kind of Harkens back to those
movies where it's like about the evil
Corporation trying to do the thing
because they want to get more money and
you know combination with if you're
going to have a plot like that you at
least have to have characters that are
interesting enough to counterbalance
that plot but I don't think the
characters in the movie really did
anything to elevate no all right all any
of that stuff and well I think the
turtles didn't really feel like
characters and I feel like no the thing
that made them so popular the things
that made it this from this Indie comic
to This Global phenomenon that it became
like this 15 billion dollar property is
the fact that we endear ourselves to the
turtles because we see ourselves in the
Ninja Turtles themselves and I think the
movie didn't really have a care or Focus
or even confidence to treat them as
these leads or as these characters to
really have us root behind them because
nothing in the movie gave us that sense
of oh we gotta root for these turtles
because we love these guys and they they
did a lot of lip service the fact that
all their brothers or the teenagers but
I think the main thing they focused on
with the fact that they're mutants and I
think they forgot about the other stuff
they didn't really care to explore any
of the other stuff I'm 100 on the same
page with you everything about them felt
perfunctory it felt rote it felt like we
got it it reached these certain beats
obligatory yeah like just the most basic
type of you gotta hit in your plot
points and then the only thing they
asked themselves or what can we do
aesthetically that's different you know
what I know let's make it really slick
and gritty okay we want to take we want
to be the badass serious one that's the
only thing they provided that was
different but really it is surface I
feel like it it it poses as this
dramatic Hefty piece with its amount of
slo-mo and serious no eyebrow wrath I
love you girl like it poses as that but
it it's ultimately Hollow yeah and
um and and so I I do feel like you're in
this hat the script look at this
description look at this
bigger and better notice Blockbuster hit
loaded with non-stop action and laughs
kind of uh yeah it like the thing is
there's so much to providing a feel for
a movie you know and I'll and a lot of
times aesthetically that is a part of
the feel that you get but the look of
this movie I felt really undercut
whatever they wanted to have endearing
and heartfelt Vibes about it because the
look to it
um and the camera movement to it
I just never felt like I could connect
to yeah just felt lifeless I felt
like one of those movies that they make
just to keep the rights to the property
and the act like the the only time I was
really enjoying it was sometimes we will
learn that like the part that weirdly I
thought they could have magnified more
was when they had April willarnette and
Raphael together there was something
about that few minutes that made me go I
feel like there would have been a real
movie here somewhere
Dynamic there uh of those three excuse
me speeches totally flew out of my mouth
but those three types of personalities I
thought oh you know there's a kind of an
interesting Dynamic here but
it it's got that again that Michael Bay
Transformers effect that whatever the
turtles are on screen it they're like I
can tell them apart I can but there's so
much focus on like blending with the
background and not popping that the when
the camera's moving it's just like this
one
one blurred emit not blurred uh what's
the word I'm trying to look like
everything just kind of feels like
morphed together in one imagery right
like when you think about those Michael
Bay Transformers films where you're like
what okay I can I can I can tell what's
going on in the action but it's still
kind of all meshing together a little
too much and that's kind of how I felt a
lot with this visual noise and I think
that's why I like out of the action
scenes it was the snow sequence because
like oh the turtles are actually popping
here like you can actually really see
them like contrasted against the snowy
backdrop yeah and I think like towards
the second half I did that movie that
thing where movies do we're just like uh
we don't have enough character to
to really make this movie pop so we're
gonna do is we're gonna have action
scene after action scene after action
scene without having anything to like
really give it Stakes or give us a
reason to care in between those action
scenes if like half the movie from the
point where
maybe yeah from the point where the they
their base was invaded to the very end
of the movie it was just nothing but
action scenes and nothing really kind of
made us care more about the turtles and
their interactions or April during those
action scenes I feel like maybe I don't
know because I think the fact that April
was so clean and so polished the entire
time coupled with the fact that she
didn't really have any flaws as a
character even made her even seem more
flat well you didn't really get to hang
out with the turtles
like they're so kept as
I don't see the point in doing
it honestly because it's like we know
it's the turtles exactly that's why
we're here yeah it's the Ninja Turtles
they've been around for decades like
just just show us just go to the turtles
don't try to play this like super
mysterious Factor when you're not really
gonna pay them mysterious Factor off at
all
um
like you get the turtles fight they
interact with April for a little bit and
that's all from April's POV and then
they have like two minutes with shredder
not a shredder but Splinter when he's
tempting him with the pizza so that way
they can reveal the information
and then like that that's their second
scene and then you uh you they they
kidnap they bring April Back to the
Sewer they give the origin and then oh
my God the freaking Foot Clan is
attacking them and Switzer might die no
I'm my God but by that point
we didn't spend enough time truly spend
enough time with the turtles other than
finally getting like the background on
them but the second you get the
background suddenly oh my God foot Clans
here and Splinter might die I'm like how
about it I didn't really get to just
kind of
have my bonding experience with them in
order to feel like what no epic it's
sadness yeah and I think the thing is
what made the turtle so popular is the
fact that they're like this this staple
of the 90s right and I know you haven't
seen the new movie yet but something I
will say and it's not a spoiler is the
fact that they very much make them
Turtles of of this time and I feel like
this movie takes place in 2014 but
there's nothing specific enough to speak
to the experience of what it's like to
be a teenager in the 2010s Within These
group of turtles that like they took the
vague concept of turtles in which we
know on a surface level and then put it
on screen look at that Ninja Turtles but
they're not they're just what Michael
Bay did with Transporters yeah yeah like
he produced the yeah he Shadow
directed it essentially yeah it feels
that way and and to me my comparison
just keeps going back to like
Transformers rise of the Beast versus
those other ones like this needed to be
more like rise of the beasts
um where the turtles felt like actual
main characters and instead of something
that was servicing a half written plot
for April O'Neil yeah and even the
conflict within the turtles about Raph
wanted to go off on his own and then Leo
being the leader then them and then
accepting it was a very Hollow it's just
all lip service it just lost it was like
we need to do this because that's the
dynamic Raphael and Leo butt heads
because Leo's the leader and Raphael's
the uh he's the brooding one yeah but it
but it doesn't there's it's not rooted
in anything other than that's what they
have to do because they're the Ninja
Turtles it's obligatory but it's not
rooted in the plot truly at all uh it's
it's weak it's weak as hell and and a
lot of it just
there's so much else happening too and
they butchered Shredder uh I think I
think Shredder was terrible uh at first
I was like let me just see how this
Mecca suit thing goes down
but I don't know I I think try to give
the benefits it's more of like a sequel
thing that you do instead of a
first time for me at least because it's
Shredder and Shredder being so heavily
Reliant I mean one part of me was like
maybe they needed to give it to him
because they're Turtles and the turtles
are like super powered and have super
strength so yeah you need to give it to
them
I guess
um but then you okay because he had two
villains here and one really outshined
the other and what I mean outshine is
they're they're more interesting by
default of having a personality William
fickner right right one one just had
like a cool voice and a suit and the
other one was actually a person yeah but
Shredder was not a person Shredder was
not a character Shredder was
just the dude who fought and it's a lot
of knives they introduce him as if he's
going to be a character but he's not
really a character at all nor does he do
they do a good job of
like I feel like a a way that they could
does it just kept you cut up most of
that William fickner stuff you
keep Shredder
as the leader of the Foot Clan he gets
into he he fights with the turtles and
maybe he loses like early on in the
movie yeah so he needs to build so he
needs something created like I think if
you could Capital infected but you
should just really switch the Dynamics
and screen time up that way he Shredder
feels like the primary villain then
Shredder could come in with the big suit
and that way it's creating the the
personal Dynamic of Shredder versus the
turtles we're here they're just kind of
a a step in the way of Shredder versus
like him building an actual hatred
towards them or at all it's just a
couple of fight scenes you know yeah
they're not Nemesis I think that but she
I I get that it's the first one so they
don't have to be the Nemesis right away
but you can build to that by the end and
the movie does not give that impact at
all
yeah and I think if
if I don't know if this is like actual
Lord just one of the other
interpretations is that like
uh Splinter it was Shredder's rat and
like he trained him to do karate and
stuff and Granny don't used to do that
in every interpretation but I feel like
that would have even provided more uh
connectivity between the villain and the
hero and by making it April didn't
really add a ton like the fact that it
was she was uh they were her Turtles
from the beginning and didn't really
like add anything no it no it it sets it
up like it's gonna add something yeah it
sets it up like oh you're our mom or
something like that you know that they
would have some type of dynamic like
that but it doesn't really seem to have
an effect on the turtles no not the
turtles have no
they don't have any care not at all for
it and I'm like this should be a big
deal for you like this should be
um a real conversation or like no we'll
do anything for you and I'm like they do
but the movies focus and attention
there's not even much lip service as
you've been saying there's nothing much
lip service towards that fact because
but when April is the one who saved
their lives yeah and it's the reason
they're they exist they owe their
existence to her yeah
because a weird child decided to dump
these turtles in the sewer how weird her
father decided to have her daughter
[Laughter]
such an odd Choice man
yeah she didn't even like try to take
the Turtles back she was like put the
red and the turtles in the sewer
hopefully the man I guess this is better
maybe I'll survive right I don't know
and the thing is the
the movie is not fun and maybe I should
have said this like super early on
because I know most people haven't made
it this far the movie plain and simple
is not naturally fun enough
where the dumb stuff
like the dumb stuff shines so much
because this movie takes itself so
serious right whereas if they if the
movie was actually just fun
you could forgive so much of the stuff
we're talking about it because the movie
itself is fun but the movie's not fun
it's not a fun movie uh it has moments
that look cool and moments that I guess
are fun
like periodically like very periodically
but for the most part this is a really
serious film so whenever it's like not
clicking or something's becoming weak it
is not made up by an entertainment right
you know and I think that's the movie's
biggest weakness it's serious for the
sake of being serious and then because
it's established that tone you're like
oh yeah we have to be funny again we
have to find some reason to make people
laugh and most of the time it doesn't
even work like Mikey no is the only
thing that's kind of fun in the movie
it doesn't gel at all with like the
humor just feels even amongst the
turtles it feel like it feels off
because
yeah
there is something to the CGI of of them
that and the designer then that does
create some type of lack of connectivity
to them but just the way the movie's
shot and the overall mood and tone it
feels like it feels forced I think the
Voice work is not terrible I think the
choice is odd of to give them such adult
voices
especially when you keep saying they're
teenagers they're just they keep saying
it yeah and I know it's called Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles but I wouldn't have
even thought that they were teenagers
this is called the Ninja Turtles they
might as well have yeah because they
they didn't feel like teenagers not at
all and yeah so she went Raphael sounds
like sounds like a modern warfare 30
year old guy from New York
trying to do his best Mark Wahlberg I
don't know I did not understand why they
kept saying yeah there's some weird
choices I mean honestly I have to give
this movie like a freaking 5 out of ten
yeah that's a kind rating for for me
yeah I I don't I I I I was pretty
surprised by like oh this movie's not
even like entertainingly bad no it's
just so it's not bad enough Transformers
I was not I
that's the other thing too it's like I
knew he produced it I I did not have
an inkliness to just how much his voice
and style would register all over this
movie right it's like JJ Abrams produces
a lot of movies you know but like he's
he's been produced he's one of the main
producers of the Mission Impossible
movie oh okay but I'm rarely there
thinking this feels like oh JJ Abrams
movie Steven Spielberg produces a
billion movies and I'm like I'm I'm not
they're thinking that this really feels
like Michael Bay was on set right it
feels like he's very Hands-On with this
one for sure yeah and he got like the
same crew
it really does feel that way and and it
is not aesthetically and stylistically
and mood-wise it's just not my cup of
tea it is not what I personally
um jive with guys
but hey that's just me what would you
rate it Aaron as I'm trying to load
something here oh man I might go four
man
five's pretty low yeah slow
yeah I think the only thing that made it
entertaining was like the doing the
commentary part of it but just like
yeah like I get why I didn't watch this
for so long
the Patronus tab is now called audience
cool alrighty guys well thank you guys
so much for being here what did you
think about it is the second one better
let's just check Rotten Tomatoes I hope
so
I I do believe I saw the second one
I heard the second one might be better
let's look it up before we go okay
if I remember correctly from the ads I
think the bop and rock steady on that
one and um oh back to Stockman and where
all the people were talking about the
beginning and Stephen Amell
sag loving Stephen Amell
yep
out of the the 2016 one
okay so I mean it's up
it's higher than the first one okay so
this one I gave her five out of 10 and
the audience score is a 50 wow half the
people liked it okay
I get it wow I've never been more on
par with a Rotten Tomatoes consensus in
my whole life that's really the Earth
tomato says neither entertaining enough
to recommend or remarkably awful
that's exactly my problem with the
movies that's exactly what I was
thinking it's extremely new yeah all
right 40 audience like this one less but
critics liked it more for the second one
slight improvement over its predecessor
okay
all right I mean they stopped after this
one something yeah for a reason oh that
failed at the box office Sam
in total Jesus the domestic some move
some of these make more than that or the
first one made 191 million oh yeah but a
second one made 82 oh that people really
did not respond well
less than half each all right well well
guys uh yeah
um let's shout out to page from before
we go all righty Lex shout out to Alex
Aaron do an acronym for Lex
oh let's see we got Lex over here in the
house okay so we got long
ecstatic xylophone Lex you got a long
xylophone and you're really just like
what does that mean I have a long
xylophone it's just you got a lot of
notes you can play on it you got you're
versatile and your your musical uh
expertise they're very ecstatic about it
I'm just going ecstatic because that
doesn't start with X that's an e
I think xylophone starts with that I'd
have been a little bit creative here I
was trying to but one exactly one last
thing heard xylophone huh that's usually
the child's default for when they can't
find an x-word you have the internet X
word yeah you have you got a better one
Lex yeah check it
licking okay extremely
um
yeah xenophobe
okay elaborate well
Lex likes to defeat people with her
poisonous licks
and she goes in the tax xenophobes ah
um
no wait a minute no no xenophobes is the
one where uh you know like a certain
group of people
Xenomorphs are the aliens yes from Alien
does that start with x yes okay
a lot of words do you picked it you
picked the Tuffy here these are really
tough
[Laughter]
foreign
a proud Patron thanks for being here for
so long Lex you did Bob you the bomb.com
Lex
foreign